hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video selbst wahrscheinlich dass intel
eingeblendet meine mutter stellt mir
irgendwelche fragen dass das ist auch
quasi genau das was dort machen ich habe
mich mit meiner mama bei what
geschrieben hey wenn du ihn welche
fragen sie mich hast dich vielleicht in
dem video beantworten könnte dann
stellen wir dir einfach mal ich habe
halt einfach so bevor ich euch bei
instagram sage hey habt ein paar fragen
beantworte ich diesem video schreibe ich
einfach mal meiner mutter sowie stellt
er dann wahrscheinlich ganz andere
fragen und ich würde sagen wir starten
direkt mit der ersten frage ist war bei
der geburt hattest du dynamisch nur ein
paar mal um den hals herum magst du
deshalb keine schaltung am hals eng
policen direkt dass diese frage von
meiner mutter kommt und zwar erstens
hätte das einfach keiner von euch
bewusst und zweitens ja es ist einfach
so keiner stellt diese frage hast du der
sache muss ich erst mal ganz kurz was
erklären
darüber habe schon in einem video
geredet weil ich das eigentlich immer
weise nicht hat sich halt nie ergeben
oder so und waren wir auch ein bisschen
zu privat aber wenn mich meine mutter
dass wir zur frage ich habe ja gesagt
das ist ein video ist deswegen ist es
für sie wahrscheinlich auch in ordnung
bei mir war es halt so dass davon die
komplikationen waren und die nabelschnur
irgendwie als ich halt raus gekommen bin
um meinen hals rumba und ich wäre heute
fast erstickt und fast gestorben andere
youtuber würden das video jetzt
wahrscheinlich ich bin fast gestorben
nennen oder so aber ich will das nicht
sondern weil ich da wir haben spaß und
ich war halt selber nicht so daran
beteiligt selber nicht schuld und ich
will jetzt auch gar nicht in so einer
depri phase abrutschen also ich bin es
auch überhaupt nicht irgendwie sensibel
was dieses thema angeht aber die
nabelschnur war halt und mein kopf rum
und dass muslime der chefarzt kommen und
die irgendwie so entfernen und meine
eltern sagen wir deshalb mega häufig
dass sie total froh sind dass ich diesen
tag aber überlebt habe quasi also die
nabelschnur war quasi mein traum und ich
war halt fast gestorben bei der geburt
die frage war aber ob ich deshalb keine
chance und engen police mag das weiß ich
gar nicht ob das einfach so eine ruby
ist aber es ist wirklich so ich trage
wenn ich sage dann immer nur so runter
jetzt ein bisschen lockerer sind am hals
und ich hatte auch ketten und alles
möglich ich komme damit hat auch nicht
klar in pullover mega eng sind
deswegen hatte ich halt auch die
pullover dies gibt relativ selten an sag
ich mal in videos weil ich halt doch ein
bisschen enger geschnitten sind also die
meisten menschen glaube ich 90 prozent
aller menschen finden es cool denn
klamotten nicht so ausgefallen sind dann
guck mal hier diese das ist auch schon
relativ weit hoffe ihr versteht so ein
bisschen was ich meine aber mama ich
weiß nicht ob das einhergeht aber stimmt
es kann sein dass da eine gewisse
verbindung besteht ist du eigentlich
wasserscheuen ein seepferdchen bestanden
hast dann kann man bestehen wusstest
wolltest du erstmal nicht schwimmen fast
egal wenn ich weiß dass gar nicht mehr
das ist eigentlich wäre so die stellt
fragen
ich kommentiere das irgendwie darüber
könnte man ihm ein buch schreiben will
meinem wagen braucht irgendwelche fakten
raus und ich kommentiert ist deshalb
eigentlich echt ne geile buchidee kann
ich tatsächlich nicht beantworten also
ich weiß nicht mehr wie oder war nicht
das seepferdchen gemacht habe ich glaube
das war sogar im urlaub aber wasser bin
ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht also ich
hatte früher angst von dem beckenrand
ins wasser zu springen mittlerweile okay
das höchste von dem ich gesprungen waren
drei meter turm habe ich selbst auch
einfach nicht ein dass ich fünf meter
hoch gehen nur um urteil zu sprechen
anstatt das nicht so viel zu tun also
ich habe respekt vor der höhe aber jetzt
keine krasse höhenangst aber was das
soll würde ich mich eigentlich auch
nicht netten mama kannst du spanisch
haut wie die in fahrt wieder raus aber
ich bereue ich hatte auf dem gymnasium
spanisch und ich habe mich darauf
gefreut ich habe schon so kurse vorher
gemacht mit diesem leo wörterbuch und so
und der unterricht war megabyte so wir
hatten eigentlich den coolsten
spanischlehrer dienst irgendwie gar aber
ich habe zu der zeit halt deutsch
leistungskurs englisch leistungskurs
latein mit dem abi knob und dann noch
spanisch dazu und das hat mein kopf
etwas zu explodieren gebracht deswegen
habe ich spanisch quasi nach dem jahr
zum abgebrochen und habe es dann an der
uni noch mal angefangen das war vor
anderthalb jahren an der uni und ich
habe das mit einem kumpel aus luxemburg
gemacht man musste irgendwie wir uns so
oft anwesend sein und irgendwann
zertifikat zu bekommen ich war genauso
zweifel anwesend weil das mich auch
wieder komplett sind also spare ich das
echte holte coole sprache und ich bin
schon noch ein paar grundkenntnisse aber
irgendwie hat das zwischen spanisch und
mir nie so wirklich eine richtige liebe
ergeben würdest du gerne anders heißen
als luca ja definitiv ich finde den
namen an sich wirklich ultra cool und
den haben wir frauen nicht so viele also
mittlerweile ja immer mehr aber ich bin
halt auch schon 20 und die meisten leute
hier wahrscheinlich kennen die flughäfen
sind irgendwie unter 20 bei mir war es
halt auch noch so dass ich einen zweiten
namen brauchte weil zu dem zeitpunkt
irgendwie luca noch nicht vollständig
als männer name irgendwie in den büchern
festgehalten wurde irgendwie so also ich
würde gern anders heißen aber einfach
nur weil ich ein mensch bin der
beständigkeit mag also ich muss auch
irgendwie immer umziehen oder wo auch
immer neue sachen irgendwie oder so also
ich behalte bock auf was neues aber ich
bin eigentlich zufrieden mit meinem
wolltest du früher mal feuerwehrmann
werden ich habe keine ahnung wie sie auf
diese frage kommt oder ob das irgendwie
hintergrund hat weil ich vielleicht mal
als feuerwehrmann an karneval gegangen
bin aber eigentlich wollte ich nie
feuerwehrmann werden weil ich ein
bisschen platzangst habe und ich hatte
keinen bock irgendwelche häuser
reinzulaufen wo alles neben mir
einstürzt und alles am brennenden ist da
will ich glaube ich noch heulen
also nein nie feuerwehrmann magst du
müsse bis zum wandel sind gesund wenn
man nicht allergisch ist
keine frage also ich mag nüsse und
mandeln und alles und auch im müsli
finde ich das ultra cool weil ich bin
halt immer ein dass es ihnen die
ungesund ist weil ich hätte mich
erinnert das wenn ich müsste es ja immer
so an diese müsse diese früheren design
hätten panade und alles mögliche dran
waren irgendwelche nix mit paprika und
salz oder so war darum michael dann
müsse halt immer ein cocktail bars wo
müsse in so kleinen schälchen drin sind
wo 10.000 leute reinpassen und deswegen
bin ich müsste quasi immer mit irgendwie
ungesund unhygienisch deswegen er sich
halt nicht so oft müsse und mama weiß
das glaube ich auch dass wir zu hause
weil meine eltern haben wir halt
irgendwie 34 verschiedene sorten von
mies und in allen sind irgendwie nüsse
drin und ich sortiere die immer raus
durch deine scheinbar positive energie
ziehst du immer tiere an welches
haustier hättest du nochmal am liebsten
ich habe keine ahnung was das zu fragen
sind so wenn ich euch dargestellt wir
fragen kommt so etwas wie magst zu
pflanzen oder was dein lieblingstier und
manchmal heute mal so einen riesigen
roman rausch hatte bisher in meinem
leben ein haustier und das war ein
löwenkopf zwergkaninchen mein kaninchen
hieß krümmel und das von meiner
schwester ließ klopfer und es waren
falls sie unsere tiere dann früher und
dann ist eins von den beiden halt
gestorben und dann haben sie das andere
abgegeben weil kaninchen alleine zu
halten ist nicht gut für die frage war
glaube ich irgendwie auch mein lieblings
haustier oder so bezogen also ich hätte
wirklich eigentlich unglaublich gern
schildkröten weil das einfach so übels
gezielte tiere sind die musste halt
nicht gassi gehen oder irgendwie sowas
oder die schilder einfach nur rum und
ich find es einfach mega entspannt wenn
ich irgendwie an einem sonntagmorgen im
bett liegende schildkröte zu mir zu
chillen und dann irgendwie keine ahnung
dass man dann
ich weiß nicht ich hab keine arbeit habe
ich überhaupt wieder träumen von einem
hund oder katze oder so als haustier
aber da bin ich gar nicht so krass der
fan von weil das hat mit sehr viel
arbeit verbunden aber ja ich hätte
eigentlich mal bock auf eine schildkröte
das was ihr von dem video meine damen
und herren ich hoffe euch hat das
gefallen
das auf jeden fall mal lag da wie gesagt
ich hab meiner mama einfach mal gesagt
wieso wir mal ein paar fragen stellen
die ich in einem video beantworten darf
und ich hoffe das war jetzt für euch
wisst ihr was cool ist also ein kleiner
einblick findet hier in smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf hier könnt
ihr einen kanal abonnieren wir auf jeden
fall schädlich weil irgendwie weiß nicht
ich also neue abonnent ist einfach cool
des total von der familie und hier
findet ihr ein video eingeblendet wo ich
irgendwas anderes gemacht habe ich weiß
nicht steht da drauf und das war's